all right
Brandon Brandon where you from
originally where'd you grow up uh Kansas
what part OA it's about 20 minutes south
of Kansas City Kansas on the Kansas side
not Missouri yeah tell me about your
family um so I U you know my mom and dad
got married and then uh my mom already
had my brother but he's 361 days older
than me and um then they had me in May
and about you know she's
uh you know 20 months younger than me so
we're all real close you know in between
um but uh when we were 1 two and three
something happened I don't I don't ask
questions really I tried a few times but
uh my mom end up leaving my dad just in
the night cuz they argued all the time I
guess and uh left left him and uh so he
was a struggling single father for a a
few few years and she finally I
initially remember her coming back into
my life around 6 years old and with the
new stepdad and all that was crazy to me
um so I had to adapt to two new siblings
um but I was very loyal to my dad
because that's all I knew was my dad so
uh you know uh I you know I grew up you
know just basically being devoted to my
father
uh so majority of your childhood was
with your dad or with your mom oh my my
dad yeah so you when your mom came back
at 6 years old she it was it was the uh
every other weekend or every two year
two weekends yeah and then every other
um summer type thing every and then um
we'd switch with
thanksgivings um everything like that my
brother when he was 12 he ended up
moving with my uh mom and that kind of
broke my dad's heart broke my heart cuz
that was my brother and we're Irish
twins because we're only 361 days apart
um and then even at 16 my sister ended
up moving with my mom cuz she didn't
like the uh discipline because my dad
was older uh 11 years older than my mom
um uh and he's an old country boy from
Kansas so you know they believe in
spankings and and in discipline and you
know don't talk back and everything like
that and my mom grew up an orphan so
she'd never believed in and she's a twin
she never believed in um spanking and
everything like that so um it was it was
rough on on both of us to lose both my
siblings um but by that time I I
resented my mom until I was 12 years old
because I was just so loyal to my dad
cuz that's all I knew and it was just
then at you know six 15 years old it's
just me and him now and then I'd go see
my mom if I could you know every other
week weekend or every couple weeks and
then my brother and sister would come
down and visit if they could but at that
time we were becoming teenagers so you
know we might have stuff to do what was
your life like with your dad uh it was
you know it was it was rough after it
was just me and him um unfortunately um
I had to drop out of school at 16
because um some issues happened and he
got on the U sex offender list uh
unfortunately
um so I ended up he couldn't get a job
and he hurt his back and he had a steel
plate in his arm um when I was about 10
years old so it was already hard for him
to get a job even at like a convenience
store so when that happened nobody's
going to hire you in Kansas you know cuz
it
there's just not that many opportunities
and let alone the experience that he has
was mostly
construction um so I had to drop out of
school at 16 and start paying all the
bills you know I was paying an
equivalent to Kansas it was $700 a month
which is a lot you know um back then so
it was it was very stressful at at that
point but um you know I tried but I
still love my dad I I never regretted
anything I never um you know was ashamed
of of him I supported him and everything
um and never never judged them so at 16
you became the bread winner yeah 16 I I
dropped out of school and uh I was
making 213 an hour at IHOP plus tips but
you know guys don't make as much tips
you know as as women um most of the time
so I really we were we're staying in a
hotel a roach motel that's you
know 150 200 square ft um paying $800 a
month and it was it was nasty but we did
that for a year um until I was able to
uh get my
GED uh at on the day I turned 17 then we
moved over across the street to get a
studio apartment which was a little bit
bigger but he slept in the kitchen on a
cot and I slept in the front room on a
futon and uh I just you know it was only
450 a month so we were cutting bills in
half um but we didn't have food stamps
nothing like that we were waiting on his
disability that way he could bring in
some income because like I said he he
was already disabled he had a heart
heart disease um congestive heart
failure he already had four heart
attacks by that time and he had a open
heart double bypass open heart which uh
he had nine stance put in which was a
hospital record and the he was a hard
smoker so the doctor told him you got to
stop smoking and what he heard was stop
smoking cigarettes but I can switch to
Cigars um
and his family my his brother and sister
you know that helped raise us my aunt
was our our daycare provider when we
were children cuz she wouldn't charge
them when he could work but uh they were
no that's that's not what it means it it
means stop smoking or you're going to
kill yourself cuz you know that's what
smoking
does so so your father lived how long uh
he lived to 59 years old um so um he
passed away when I was
25 um uh I I was working
uh my sister at at that time when I was
um about she had a baby at 16 that
passed away at still birth and then she
had um my other nephew at 18 and he had
to have a heart
transplant um when he was 8 months old
and and that was stressful too and
because my mom had gotten
remarried um you know my stepdad didn't
want to have you know a brand new baby
in in the house cuz he's kind of you
know he's he's Stern and he's like you
know hey I pay the bills around here I'm
not going to support two extra mouths
you know uh not to be mean but he's just
you know that's just how it is you know
at that time you know we were she was
only 18 so you know they were only
together a few years and um so you know
it's like it's not my kids you know you
know I'm that's my wife's kids you know
but so that was that was difficult you
know uh really difficult um so she ended
up moving in with me and my dad in a
small two-bedroom apartment and I was
sleeping on the couch and my dad was
sleeping in a tiny room and I let her
have the uh bigger room my my room that
I did have uh so she could have it with
the baby and then she ended up having
another one so then we had two and she
has anger issues and she's bipolar and
my dad has anger issues and they would
argue all the time and she got like
married but he beat her half to death so
that's why and he went to prison and
that's why she moved with us um but it
was just it was killing my dad stress
wise you know um
and I was just too busy working to
mediate anything cuz I was the bread
winner cuz my sister was taking care of
the kids during the day my dad at that
point was getting disability but it was
wasn't that much
so that's what we did for you know up
until uh uh I was able to get um save up
enough money to get a house finally that
had three levels and it was going to be
perfect my sister or uh and two nephews
would be on the bottom of the basement
with the bathroom and everything
finished me in the middle and we
actually had a kitchen a big kitchen and
my dad always wanted a big kitchen and
then we had an upstairs an attic that
was big enough for my dad so it was
perfect uh and it was it was only $800 a
month we had to switched to Missouri uh
which is fine but um 3 days later uh I
watched him die on a ventilator um from
uh heart
issues
sorry so after your dad dies then what
do you do
well I I a break down and I I start
drinking really really hard I was
already drinking for like a year and a
half after I dropped out of church um
cuz you know we I never touched a drop
until I was 25 but I just started
drinking really heavily showing up to
work drunk but passing passing off with
it because I could was a night auditor
at the time for a hotel so I was the
only one working so you know I'd have a
few shots before I went in or or four or
five shots just to get tipsy to go in
and I went to the hospital uh a few days
afterwards uh my dad died before I went
into work that was the first time I've
ever been late to work um because I
thought I was having a heart attack
because I was breaking down so much you
know and I figured heart disease runs in
the family I I I got it too probably and
I was overweight I was 270
lbs um so I was scared and that's the
only time I was ever late and I was
crying and actually my dad died on my
stepdad's birthday which I I called him
crying I said I'm sorry you know happy
birthday you know um he's like man I
understand you know but our whole family
got to be around him um but about a
month later we told the landlord please
let us you know get out of the lease you
know of the situation the whole reason
we got here was for my dad to have be
not stressed out cuz he was waiting on a
heart transplant himself um and he he
had stopped smoking but they said he had
to stopped smoking for 6 months but when
they went in to do a surgery to test his
heart um they intubated him
uh and before he died he said you know
please forgive me for everything and I
was like Dad you know cuz it was just me
and him for a long time and we were you
know and he told all three of his kids
you know please forgive me and I'm dad
you know it's
okay
um but they the landlord ended up a few
months later ended up letting us get out
of the lease and we moved to our our
mom's house in
Missouri uh and then uh I I got a call
from uh you know Delta Airlines that I
got approved for a flight ATT tenant
position that I'd been interviewing for
for months and I was ecstatic because
that's a dream job of mine cuz at that
point I'd already been to uh 18
countries and about 38 States uh because
I worked hard and I that's why I had so
many jobs because I would quit but I
would save up money and I was a gambler
too so I would win jackpots and save up
money so how many jobs did you have I
had 65 jobs by the time I was 18 years
old because I I got bored I one I one
day at Little Caesar's that's all I
lasted and I got fired two days at a a
another place cuz I was like this ain't
for me you know and I I believe like you
know they say you know do what you love
and I figured you know I don't have a
college degree I I barely got a high
school diploma I don't have any
experience really because you know I
can't build a resume so I have to lie I
bought my first car you know by figuring
out the numbers of what taxes would be I
lied about that I was kind of proud of
myself um so I I tricked the bank and
the uh dealership into give me my first
car that way um because I I am smart you
know I am I'm street smart and school
smart but I did the math and everything
but so you worked as as a flight
attendant for long I worked as a flight
attendant for two and a half years I
worked in the top 5% of many how many
hours you work because there's there's
you know certain um you know regulations
FAA regulations but I was working you
know 6 days a week you know sometimes
you work 15 16 hours a day and you're
only getting paid for four of them
because you only get paid from when the
doors are closed and push back from the
gate when we have a six-h hour layover
like in the airport waiting we don't get
paid for that so I don't know the rules
now because it's been a couple years but
I did that for 2 and A2 years and and
uh um the day before my interview I
watched my dad's brother um who's like
15 years older than him uh die same way
intubated in a
coma uh he he just went in just for a
little thing the doctor said
everything's going to be fine nothing
ever happens you got small veins but you
know I'm I'm one of the best there is
and so we're like you know but I for
some reason I called him a few days
earlier and I said I want to be there
and he's like you don't have to be there
I want to be there so I got to tell him
goodbye so that helped and the next day
I went to interview took me 6 hours
interview um cuz they hire less than 2%
of applicants so uh I got I got it and I
was ecstatic because I felt accomplished
for once that I finally get to follow my
dreams cuz I never traveled as much
before and I wanted to do it before but
I didn't want to leave my dad on his own
cuz I worked wored about my dad you know
all the time about him being lonely cuz
he he never had a girlfriend or anything
my whole life he was and and I mean cuz
at one point you got to
disclose you know your background of of
having that offense and that's just too
humiliating for him and you know I
understand that um but um so I did that
for two and a half years but the after
the first year um my uh 5-year-old
nephew that had the heart transplant on
on January 1st
died and I was on the plane and we were
boarding
and you know it was it was just I broke
down in the bathroom for about 15
minutes and I said what can I do and
then I uh picked myself up finished
boarding finished the flight finished my
whole trip and then uh I asked them
that's the first time I I ever asked
time off I was ever late I was never
late but I first time I asked off in my
whole life I've never had vacation so I
took time off I went and paid for my
son's uh nephew's funeral uh and I was
sicker than a dog and that's around when
Co started so I may have had one of the
first cases of Co I don't know but so
that didn't
help um but I I just started drinking
even more cuz on the planes I just would
steal the little bottles I'd steal eight
to 10 of them a night and I built up
such a tolerance that I'd have to drink
more and more and if you have a 24-hour
layover in Costa Rica and I was making a
lot of money most money any body made so
I could didn't have to steal but I'm
like you know I'm I'm used to being poor
of my life up up until that point so I'm
like you know you might as well take
what's free um but you know I would buy
a fifth and drink it in in 5
hours um but when I got fired just I had
to move to my mom's and the for the
first time I wasn't able to take care of
anybody and and it really just CU I was
gambling while I was drinking I gambled
through over $100,000 a year um and that
was ruining my life cuz I was in debt
maxed out like three cards slots I I did
slots um but I was good at it I did high
limit I would do anywhere from you know
$12 to $125 a win and when I left uh I
was based in Boston and then Detroit
when I left Detroit I left with
$43,000 uh and in 8 hours uh and that
was gone in uh 3 weeks because of all my
gambling um but you know I just I I
moved with my mom and I just felt
humiliated and then all I did because I
had a little bit of savings was just
drink and my stepdad hated it because I
it depended on how I was just I was just
sitting there with my mom all day cuz
she can't work she she became disabled
and uh so I was just enjoying time with
my mom so that's one good thing my
sister end up getting a place with a
friend of hers
um and she ended up having a little girl
um so um at that point uh I was just
drinking all day and by the time my
stepdad got
home he's drunk again you know telling
my mom and and she's like I I know he
and they would get in arguments and I'd
feel bad about it but then if I'm in a
aggressive State I'd get an argument
with him and I'm like don't blame my mom
for this you know it's not her
fault but
eventually my sister got got her own
place in Kansas and that's when they
were in Missouri and my stepdad told my
mom he's he's got to go if he's not
going to stop drinking and he's not
going to get a job cuz I tried to get a
job but I showed up drunk like drunk and
I got an argument with the manager and
uh so you know I I quit I walked out um
and I was drinking and driving and
luckily I I I never got pulled over
forward or never wrecked or nothing so
I'm grateful for that and I know I don't
condone it but um so my mom's like you
know he's he's the bread winner I don't
make no money so I mean now my sister's
got a
place you know and my sister's like okay
but if you come here you can't drink I
said all right you know okay I I'll get
a job or I'll help I'll help watch the
kids because a daycare is super
expensive for a single mom in Kansas
when minimum wage is still 725 and she
was only making 11 bucks an hour trying
to pay $700 in rent um
so I said all right so I started helping
out with the kids watching the kids at
my sister's house living with her um but
then I I uh just kept drinking and if I
couldn't afford it I'd go steal it and
if I got caught I would just run uh
because I didn't have no money I didn't
have no job so I would have to borrow
money from my mom and then then my
stepdad would and my sister would get
stop enabling him and then sometimes I'd
steal from my sister like you know if
she had like her U debit card out or
something I'd say I'd go to the store
and buy something and cuz I knew she
didn't have the checking app cuz she you
know didn't keep track of she's bad with
money so she won't notice you know like
a $5 bottle you know and that'll get me
eight shots and she'll see me over there
drinking like this you know and she are
you drinking again I was like what no
and then she was like don't lie to me
and so we we got an arguments a lot and
it became really toxic uh and and
eventually uh I got caught stealing and
I got pulled over and and I'd been
drinking all day so luckily they didn't
get me for drunk driving but they got me
for lying to them CU I told them a wrong
name cuz I didn't want to go to jail I
thought I was going to go to jail and uh
I I got my first uh booking so I didn't
go to jail but they gave me a ticket I
went to the court they said just you
know we're not even going to charge you
for the theft just we're going to charge
you for lying to the police um my
sister's like look dude you're ruining
your life you're hurting yourself and
and at that time I'd already been to the
hospital twice for bad withdrawals when
I did try to stop because I would stop
cold turkey and they and I guess they
say and I try to lie to them saying guys
I can't stop cold turkey you know the
doctor says I'm not supposed to and oh
that's that's bull you know they you're
lying to us I'm like no I promise Google
it but I just go steal more during the
day because my sister was working and
sometimes
um if if she had daycare for my niece my
nephew was at school cuz he was five at
the
time if I had to watch my niece I'm in
there stuffing drinks in the car seat
not proud of it you know I'm laughing
because it's so stupid of how desperate
I was but I I became so addicted and and
after I called the cops on
myself twice and I did get booked in the
drunk tank I woke up naked in a suicide
vest
um that was kind of a like dude if you
don't stop drinking then I got to K I'm
sorry you got to go and this is around
January in Kansas so it's 25° outside
and I'm thinking you know I I want to
get better I do and they're like no you
don't cuz you keep drinking and prove it
it's just really hard with addiction um
what do you think people don't
understand about that situation the the
strength of it you know the when you're
so desperate that's your only
relief uh you know I don't want to be a
Pill Popper you know I don't want to go
to the doctor and get on a bunch of
anxiety and depression medicines CU I
was depressed because of my situation
because of my nephew and my uncle and my
dad all within you know 15 months dying
and I've never my grandma died in '97
when I was four years old so that that's
the first time my dad was the first
funeral went to so I wasn't used to it
the loss have you ever been in
love well that's a that's a when I was
uh 20 years old I met a girl online from
church on Facebook and uh we ended up
talking and she was from
Guatemala and um we Skyped every day for
six months and they're like oh she's one
of those you
know uh ones that are faking their ID
and I said no no guys I I'm looking at
her you know and so I said well I'm
going to buy a ticket I'm going to come
down there and I'm going to propose to
you and so I uh I at 20 years old I went
down to Guatemala my first international
flight and uh well my my first flight
ever actually my first international
flight and I went down there 6 days
later I proposed 4 days later I flew
back to
Kansas uh so I was deep in love and the
way I knew I was in love in my head
because I had girlfriends but I never
thought about cheating on her cuz you
know I would and I wouldn't look at
other girls and lust after them or
anything I'm like no I'm grateful for
what I got and I was in church at the
time so I had a in a very strong church
so P you know very strong beliefs and
you're not supposed to have sex before
marriage you know women have to wear
skirts men have to wear pants you know
you can't live together until you're
married and so I'm like you know feeling
guilty about you know talking to her and
and then we were wanting to do stuff and
I want to get married because I was
getting told that I was going to die
soon basically because of the Rapture so
I was like I want to hurry up and get
married so I wanted to speed this thing
up but I had to sit in a room with her
mom in front of her and her two brothers
and they translated and had to ask
permission in front of my fiance cuz she
said yes and I thought this is so I was
like this is a red flag I should I
should have known
but long story short you know uh I go
she comes with her mom cuz her mom
wouldn't let her come by herself even
though she was 5 years old to me
25 um to Kansas and then I went back for
about 20 days in November and uh I had
to break things off just cuz she
couldn't become independent so that's
about the only time I've ever been in
love when I was
20 other than that you know I I really
just was started just getting addicted
to money and then I started gambling you
know and I was like you know hey I like
making money I'm just going to make
money plus I have to provide for my
family so the drinking unraveled at all
yeah yeah I mean I mean the drinking was
it's it's a depressant you know but for
me it was a high and you know it became
to the point when I'd get addicted to it
if I didn't drink it like now you know I
I can't sleep I haven't slept for 4 days
you know because I'm trying to get off
again and that's why I look so tired I
think and uh so what brought you out to
LA my sister kick me out well because
that last
altercation we got in a fight Argent
because I was drunk by noon and I lived
upstairs and she was like dude you know
I come home and you're drunk like like
piss drunk already I'm like no I'm not
like I'm fine you know I'm just watching
TV she was like do you need to get out
dude and I'm like where am I going to go
it's 25° she I don't care you got to
find
somewhere and we got in a fight she
locked loock the door and I was banging
on the door trying to break it down I
ended up you know screaming yelling and
I ended up punching her window in and I
have a
scar and uh the cops came and they
arrested me and uh the next day they
said you're not allowed to go back to
your your sister's house and I
said okay but the next day when I got
out I went straight to my sister's house
and I'm like you know because she would
always her and my mom would always we'd
get into arguments but at the end of the
day they they would dude we need to do
something about this and so we talked to
my stepdad cuz she didn't have no money
my mom didn't have no money I didn't
have no money my stepdad was the only
one with money so we I said cuz I was
based here in uh Englewood for a year as
a flight attendant so I knew the weather
and it's February so I'm like you know
what I know that area if you'll just buy
me like a plane ticket or a train ticket
out to LA I'll pack my bags and I'll
just go out there and and wing
it so that's what we did because I'd
rather be in 60° weather than 20°
weather and you're homeless now on
skidrow oh yeah yeah homeless and uh I
wasn't I I was homeless for two weeks
and then I try to shelter for two months
but I got kicked out because I I got
back on the bender and I would I in the
last how much are you drinking
now 15 shots a day if I can if I can if
I can buy it it's 15 shots a day if I
can steal it then it's it's usually
about you know seven uh celor and that's
but I have such a high tolerance that it
doesn't really get me it doesn't get me
super drunk it just gets me Tipsy but
the 15 shots will get me drunk enough to
put me to sleep um but it's a coping
mechanism because it's so stressful out
here because I've never seen we don't
have homeless people in Kansas you know
it's so sparse and everything and and
yeah the winter suck but you know
usually you have some maybe one or two
shelters out there I come here and I've
I've never seen tents like this I mean
the only way place I can compare to is
uh Vegas I saw Tent City in Vegas and I
thought that was crazy um but I come out
here and uh they gave me money to buy a
tent so I bought a small little a tent
cuz I was like I'm not going to go to a
shelter I'm just going to you know get
my stuff together and and make some get
a job make some money and get a big tent
and just make my own little apartment
but that hasn't happened no cuz I was
like getting tired of the sirens every
night and the loud booms and the and the
people smoking yelling and arguing at 2
3 4:00 in the morning so it stressing me
out so I was like man if I'm going to
change maybe I should look into a
shelter so I went to a shelter and that
only lasted two uh two months cuz I fell
off the wagon and they kicked me out and
my
buddy got kicked out the week before me
and so I saw him and I was like hey you
know we might as well try to at least be
together so it's safer because it's
people are you see dead bodies or you
see people you hear gunshots it's
dangerous here it is so we we lasted 3
months one block away from here and we
ended up getting robbed at gunpoint and
getting told and they shot it off so we
knew it was real and I've never dealt
with guns you know I've heard gunshots
but I've never dealt with guns but to
have one in my face it you know it'll
change you uh so we're were like okay
you know we'll leave
so I ended up going to Santa Monica that
night and pulling a fake gun out on a
security guard a BB gun and so now I
have to go to court here in a few weeks
for that and so now I got a warrant
warrant out in Kansas because I wasn't
able to show up to court and I already
missed my court date last week
so you know I'm just people all the time
talk down to me here because I am a
minority and and uh in skid R and just I
have no say and I have a mouth on me
because I come from Kansas I'm an old
school boy too so I'm used to respect
and when I don't say nothing to you and
you disrespect me from the get-go like
hey you can't sit there and I'm like
dude I'm just waiting for lunch I'm in
line like nah ma get out of here I talk
back and people have warned me dude
you're going to get killed out here with
that mouth and I'm like well yeah you
know I just I don't like that disrespect
I didn't do nothing to them but you
can't have that mentality out here
everybody's High everybody's High
dancing in the street I like the happy
ones but the the aggressive ones that
are arguing and fighting all the time
and i' I've gotten in a fist fight with
a guy that when I was drunk and he was
high I don't even know why I can't
remember it wasn't even at my tent but
so now you know I'm trying to get out of
skid road because I'm or get back into a
shelter because I really am am trying to
get my life together and and get back on
track cuz I mean it's killing me I've
been Hospital hospitalized four times
since since I've been out here because
of severe withdrawals um and I already
have therosis pancreatitis and fatty
liver damage the beginning stages but
they they told me you're going to you're
not going to live to 35 if you keep on
how old do you know 30 you're 30 and and
I already have a a fear of death you
know and which is
ironic so you know I'm like man it's not
worth it you know I'm I'm I'm used to
being I was poor and then I went on a
high and made something of myself and I
made more money than anybody else in my
family and then that just all came
crashing down and now I'm at the worst
of anybody in my family and that's just
it's so emotionally uh draining you know
so now I'm I'm just I'm desperate I I
like I said the only money I have is the
benefits that I've never had before I
get food stamps and I get 220 bucks a
month other than and I pushed the cans
which I always saw those people and I
was like if I get to that point I'm
going to go back to Kansas if I can but
here I am pushing cans you know making
$6 for 6 hours of
work um or or trying to Panhandle but
because I you know because I'm young I
guess they and I'm not dirty you know
because I I try to still have a standard
for myself they just nobody gives me
money is there anything you've learned
from all of this that you've been
through yeah don't don't don't do drugs
don't get addicted to anything just and
have a sober mind you know stay grateful
for what you have you know love the
people around you uh just learn from
your mistakes and grow from them don't
turn back to them you know cuz it's a
repeating cycle of of what I'm doing and
if you don't stop you're going to kill
yourself and it's not worth it all right
well thank you so much for sharing your
story yeah thank you for having me I
wish you all the luck in the world
Brandon thank
you